hello and welcome to this video playing
wouldn't get see far this is a German
rod but an American flag that actually
means past those little insects or
whatever that that can I get to your
place okay what a crew is seven ok so it
does not take on d fone c6 now which is
the normal continuation hmm interesting
so Knight f6 looks completely looks
logical so let's do it now with this
Bishop g5 business the the whole loan g6
setup looks a bit strange but it is not
that bad here I think I should just
castle short him
you have the dark squares look a little
bit problematic I have to admit that but
it still looks fairly very salty
everything um 94 the screen to F form
does it look very very nice 595 so maybe
I can go for the fee Aikido this one
yeah
okay so got that feelin kettle 'if I've
doesn't look dangerous this looks
dangerous though Queen f8 probably Queen
to g5 yeah but I don't have much choice
Queen g7 not so happy with it but don't
don't see a big alternative because our
Terms prolly we had english promising
alternative yeah okay the set list gives
me the d5 square even though 94 94 is
probably an issue mmm I did not want to
play Knight to d7 but maybe I have to
that's not so bad I think
rock the window roop t1 okay i probably
have f6 we should or bishop f3 and then
f6 this is actually interesting f6 okay
let's go for it or h6 age six days
Queenie 70
it takes on f6 night takes 94s actually
a problem if you take one I have six
after the take with the Queen then okay
Jeff this I did not see which is prolly
an issue maybe maybe oh that looks like
that's Fitz fancy but strong i guess and
i have to take night takes here
threatening all kinds of stuff an i have
six first and foremost wow that looks
bad
95 I don't see a month actually c6 you
can go night c7 amongst others
I have to play well
Wow I don't know I really got into big
trouble him not entirely sure how that
happened mm-hmm whatever precise problem
was yeah this is one of the one of the
good moves okay Rupert e7 doesn't work
nine is six maybe
is f for holy moly time morning and
night of success is mate it's the thing
notify yes he has f4
threatening night age for now maybe this
can irritate him out of it he played
really really well this game so probably
it will return I want to make the thread
a little bit more serious I said could
be suicidal but anyway check so focus
you five at least loser chaps maybe it's
going to draw check and I have to do it
anyway so check check check
okay that was a very lucky winner wait
for it I got completely completely
killed completely killed wow I had
various ways to win down yeah it all
started with this I wanted to help I
wanted to hear right when he went if
I've my original intention was to go 95
but then I recognized that after night
FYI I don't really have such a great
move the computer actually gives age six
and this is good wow I did not think
about that I mean good in terms of equal
okay that said it was beyond me okay and
then I played this and now I actually
saw that it gets tricky so this is f six
takes oh this is the thing Knight f6 is
playable I thought he has this move ok I
can actually just take because this is
not a problem I didn't see that one
Queen takes f6 ok ok ok ok this is the
then this is the real reason for my
problems that I now felt that this is
forced and Jack here I got into huge
trouble I mean this is this is just
and just a completely rotten position
Jim not happy about this but hmm yeah
this is okay this is probably good but
the easiest this is for him to this is
also what i expected that he checks and
just takes here takes his seven so and
this was what i expected and it's really
terrible i cannot move anything here if
I move yeah yeah Lou the computer gives
this as the strongest ideas this this
and this is like plus 4 yeah as I said
he completely outplayed me him I was
just try to to hang on and ya know I
have some kind of idea yeah this was
gambling I wanted to get this this kind
of counter play even though when
probably is not great chechik and yeah
kinking f1 is stronger yeah I just
getting out of the trick there he
stumbled into that trick now he
absolutely cannot take g5 if he does not
he probably still is better you know and
the engine is is below plus one at least
so there they are probably some some
chances it wants to do this that's not
not easy now for a human to to play with
20 seconds on the clock yeah no idea
this is what the engine and wants to
play
check yeah for human players this is
probably going to be full of mistakes
yeah but he blundered into that channel
check check check ok King g7 the strong
of it ok I couldn't really walk into
happy to have found that this is pretty
clean win just trade trade it down when
you have little time well ok so there
was rather lucky thanks for watching